[MUSIC]
I grew up drawing my whole entire life,
figure drawing primarily,
and I would say my junior year in college
is when I actually started painting more seriously.
I immediately shifted into
using unconventional materials.
I started using objects
from my own childhood,
things with a certain
luster or polish to them.
Thinking back on China cabinets and
these little beautiful encrusted plates,
creating that fiction of glamour,
of decadence, of wealth
I think is something that's heavily
engrained into drag culture that always fascinates me,
but it's also heavily engrained into black culture.
Looking at even certain places
where I went to school growing up,
a lot of people felt the importance
of wearing gold chains,
a ton of jewelry or young women
wearing bamboo gold hoop earrings
with their names enscrawled in them.
Those types of things to me all kind of conflate
into wanting or desiring
to appear much more than one
maybe feels that they are or
deserve to be.
[MUSIC]
Even as a child I would very rarely
go to the barbershop, actually.
I never felt welcome in that space.
I always felt like I was too effeminate,
or I wasn't used to being around so
many hyper-masculine men.
[MUSIC]
In painting myself in "Sit Still",
the largest painting that I
made in that entire series,
there's actually the barber's hands,
who is always anonymous in
every one of those paintings,
those barber's hands
come in with a knife for
shaving my neck,
my head is tilted upwards
and so that kind of tension of yes, this
fictional space might be beautiful and
welcoming, and exciting, and fun,
and playful and lighthearted,
but it is, in reality, still unreasonable
to envision me entering that space and
feeling fully safe, even now.
[MUSIC]
>> The Warhol Museum is this,
how I see it, this perfect place for
Devan to have his first solo show.
It just connects to a history for
Devan, a history of painting,
and Devan's work brings
Warhol's work to life.
After a lot of conversations with Devan
about this body of work in Warhol's practice,
Devan started this new body of
work around trans women and drag queens
and specifically a drag queen
in Miami that he met, Miss Toto.
So that painting will be situated within
Warhol's paintings from this series,
from the Ladies Gentleman series.
[MUSIC]
I think the most important thing for
me in this exhibition is that
people leave with a new
image of what race can look like.
He's working in a long history of
painters that have come before
him that have brought light to
Black protagonists and painting
into a canon that doesn't necessarily
have the Black protagonist
as the main figure in painting.
What Devan's doing now is
creating a space to also embrace
an alternative perspective on that race.
So, queering of that identity,
bringing in the feminine,
not actually positioning the masculine
always around Blackness,
painting the flesh in different colors.
There's a painting called "Butterfly Eater"
in which the flesh of the
figure takes on the crimson sunset.
So, really challenging and complicating
our ideas around race and identity
in a really productive way.
[MUSIC]